deux ans et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
trouve avec j'ai craché voilà avec mika
l'école jordan 23 stop parfait
aujourd'hui sur lequel julianne là on
est sûr ball ala la bêta exactement
alors c'est une sorte d'imitation smash
bros on va jouer en local parce qu'on a
actuellement locale et non sa fiche en
dessous du perso de chacun pour que vous
puissiez comprendre quelque chose à
cette vidéo oui faut prendre ça ça me
plaît tu vas être qui a façonné titrage
à l'ops en garde le groupe i can't quoi
budget bon donc c'est comme un smash de
but c'est de s'exclure littéralement de
l'écran bull fois pendant quelque chose
le voyage et le ballet d'harry potter en
technologie avance assez bien moi aussi
je n'ai qu'un smicard explique airbus
sur beach à ses envies qu'apple n'en est
en fait pas tout alors vivement les
premiers mentionne ni si un plat et que
tu fais là
hop là à part non non il y avait donc on
connaît pas ce qui lui arrive à lui et
la femme de koulikoro ba ouai tournoi
oui tiens tiens les gars et nos skis et
bouge ta passion garde
j'ai mis quatre et on a tourné vers des
normes qu'on attend tous les ans par la
coupole défense epad et foncez aux buts
1 suit harry potter toi là on attend on
attend aussi les moines disponi ans
c'est à dire qu'on free jazz et a gagné
il a gagné au jeu le diverti pas faire
diversion à bamako non mais pourquoi tu
prends même que moi je prends un auteur
qui est un battant qui s'est fait ça
touchant mais il s'appelle pas qui est
ce que vous êtes pour les enfants oui on
y va la paix de l'onu
mais à quoi s'attend à mener sur la
médiane
driss el hadja ni canadien lucas ça et
attention j'ai l'euro valait d'harry
potter amical harry potter dans le vide
chaque fin d'année à hawaii un message
non n'a pas touché non cet habitant
ainsi je lui paie clos qu elle avoue
qu'à mais tous ok at on bien d'écouter
j'ai bien compris des trucs j'ai compris
les plus accomplis du tout un super tu
l'as dit là dessus s'il vous plaît je
demande le spray voilà ici présents
salut à glace et l'ajout de tahiti grèce
s'est réjoui
mais gaston perso toi attaque ça veut
dire mais c'est la sopic et
et le mot saupiquet ont été beaux
l'année mais reste à préciser
tagab et c'est qu'on a changé le mode de
jeu et que maintenant tourner la sainte
ville quand tu arrives à des rumeurs
voilà mais [ __ ] mais avec une pâte à
taux plein mais c'est hyper mais ce jeu
sans déconner la tête comme oh là là
haut tu auras faciale je suis parti
renforcent leurs richesses et moi je
suis là je suis la doublette basse je
suis parti aussi vous je vais taper jeu
d'étape et je vais me deux pistes est
désolé c'était bien tu côtoies crs 3
minutes 30 le silence ce soir aussi là
je suis encore dernier j'ai un petit on
est très fort le bouche à bouche comique
à la bombe
pour l'occasion c'est juste de la
comprimer les hauts et les bas des
poisons a vraiment fait pour améliorer
la laine de lin
[Musique]
les gallois la chine va mourir sur la
map lors terrible ma mie câline dans ce
soit et ya 9 e et le prochain euro le
jour j m si toi america tant mieux je
tiens beaucoup
ona attendait un profit tout cela mais
s'il vous plaît profitons de se revoir
des amis à la bombe en fournit 4
si j'adore c'est quand c'est ta dernière
lui tu parles l'écran bible écran de du
gagnant il ya tout le monde aléatoire
tout le monde à la toile aléatoire
aléatoire aller
oui
mairiga vous ici est gage pour moi je
suis pro dégage tu dégages c'était mieux
qu'il a pu lancer de lens ah non il
appelle maria vega nul jolies loques ya
bientôt 10 il est ici je plains dégage
ya eu des couilles
n'est ce pas la bombe une bombe platine
dj ça par contre les gars n'avaient
malheureusement ce n'est pas une bonne
mine
[Musique]
dès demain il a deviné on est tous à de
vie les gars c'est assez serré la
actuellement à un moment j'ai pas trop
envie maintenant et si je te trouve r15
esquive esquivent leurs annonces l'eau
on en gilet a touché lance l'ôter finale
3-2 grâce à toi je vais gagner
oui merci à prouve que tu existes au
pardon est ce qu'ils me connaissent
vraiment on est désolé c'est des choses
qui arrivent tous et qu'on joue aux jeux
vidéo soudainement ou autre chose et moi
c'est avec la dona ly méchante est
descendu
[Musique]
joe borg avait la tête sous cloche pour
103 fort averti est un colosse attend
jeux coquins à temps aux bombes au
[Rires]
docteur ça c'était pas très bon allez on
va essayer de la commenter un petit peu
c'est ça le plus alors on voit que donc
à plein pour les cards qui coule t elle
et lucas qui a trois vies mika qui en a
plus que deux mois sa chemise in arms a
choisi le marteau c'est le marteau là
pour lui car non mais qu'est ce que la
ville est trop longue pour lui n'a pas
d'amis il faut garder les chats il faut
y aller attention la bombe a laissé
ouakam
super équipe totalement aléatoire de
l'état c'était beau ces bons tours 3 2
et la qualité égalité deux partout at on
rayonne ça tombe bien non il est bon
teint ou un petit loto que je viens
d'essayer de camoufler luc à qui on
vient passer ni canon sur attention les
séminaires venu attention il n'a plus
que 24 à 23 secondes
c'est la dernière offre pour lui casser
la barre tuyaux de 14 500 cas ça c'est
mal et qu'on m'a dit comment tu as
l'impression que c'est le match de tenir
la méga coupe pour ball ala je remets
avenue georges s'est magnifiquement des
modernes battue à huit semaines avec
vous sortez grande émotion
félicitations vous avez emporté ce
premier tournoi d'ajoint another comme
ça tombe mal alors c'est déjà la fin de
cette vidéo avec mais kayhan ça m'a fait
plaisir de vous inviter année ce n'est
pas avoir son twitter et sa chaîne
youtube voilà si vous l'avez en vie si
vous avez long paraître ça me stresse
cédera d'écriture tout ça merci d'être
venus les gars et le mot de la fin
bol ça marche mais ça le regarde et
bientôt pis
[Applaudissements]